Hi, I'm Jeff Fisher and if
you're watching this
then you're a developer
interested in working with
google products using their APIs.
More specifically, their APIs
that use google data protocal.
So what is the google data
protocol you might ask me.
Well before I can answer that I
have to go through
some background information.
I'm assuming here you're familiar
already with
the technologies of HTTP and XML.
Now for a long time,
websites have been looking at
an alternative way of
distributing their content
in a more computer
friendly way.
Computers are not very bright
so they need
a little help understanding
our information as we see it.
So, let's look at a simple
example, such as a blog site.
So a blog site has a number of
news articles that
are displayed in a big list
and they have a summary,
a title, who wrote them,
when they wrote it.
So it's basic information.
How might we represent this
in a computer friendly way?
Well, the first attempt to
solve this problem was RSS
but the thing I'm talking
about today is
the atom syndication format.
Atom is a XML based approach
to describing the data
on these websites and making it
easy for computers
to parse this information out.
So at the basic level
you have a feed element
that contains multiple entries
and each entry will have all
the metadata associated with
the post on this blogsite.
Well that's great because now
we have a compact way of
describing all the content
on this blog.
But what if I want to create
a program that edits this blog
and not just reads it
well i could create an
entirely new mechanism to do
this and have it be drastically
different than this feed
mechanism we've already
described or
I could try and re-use it.
Well if i'm going to re-use
this format
that describes my post all
nicely in XML.
How would I transmit this data
to the server?
Since these posts are already
retrieved using HTTP,
we can just use HTTP to edit
and delete this content
as well as create
new content as well.
So great we can reuse what we
already have and just make use
of other verbs in HTTP like
put, post, and delete
and we have now a full cycle
way of managing blog content
by just editing
the feed basically.
Well what if it doesn't
have blog entries?
What if it's not a blog?
What if it's something like
a calendar or a spreadsheet
how would i represent that data?
Well
you could try
and do it in a new way
Or you could try
and use this atom method again.
And if you
use the atom method,
that's what google data
tries to do.
So,
let me show you
an example of
what an atom feed looks like.
Atom feed is XML
like what we said before
and it contains entries.
Each feed has its own metadata
as well as each entry.
You'll also notice that each
entry has a unique identifier
that makes it distinct from all
other entries on the site.
As well as some information
used to edit it.
So,
once we take this
and make it into
an editable form
we call we call this
the atom publishing protocol.
And the atom publishing protocol
extracts each of these entries
and turns them into resources.
Now these resources can either
be a traditional text resource
or they could be a media resource
such as an image file and video.
It also uses reuses the HTTP
requests that we've already
discussed to manipulate this
data and then it uses
the HTTP response codes
in order to
tell if this operation was
successful or had errors
or requires authentication.
Now this is what's
usually referred to as
a restful protocol
that uses the restful semantics
in order to modify these resources
and each request is therefore
independently of each request
and doesn't require
any additional context like a
session to know what to do.
So here we have an example post
of what it is to create
an entry on the blog
using AtomPub
and you'll notice there is
some authorization,
there is some other bits of
metadata but basically
all we're posting is
the atom entry
just like what we would get
on the atom feed.
Once we have posted this,
this bit of data we have created
this entry and we get back
the entry as we created it
with some additional members
such as an edit link
in case you want to modify it
and we also get back
some kind of version string.
in this case,
you see there is an "Etag"
which uniquely identifies the
specific revision of this post
The 201 response code
is used to indicate that
this content was successfully
created on the server.
So now what is google data?
How do I use it?
This abstract way of looking
at atom feeds.
Well, what would you need
if you wanted to represent
something that wasn't
a blog post in atom?
Probably some custom XML
that describes these entities.
And that's where kines comes in.
Gdata kines are used to
represent abstract ideas that
come across many APIs such as
what is a location?
what is a time?
what is a contact?  Things you
don't want to have to
reinvent each time you're
specifying a new API
or working with
a different product.
So once we have this XML
that fits nicely
into the Atom model.
Since atom allows you
to extend its XML.
What else might you need?
Well, there are some things
like a query language
or authentication that we
have added to atom pub
as part of google data.
Google data basically allows us
to fill in the cracks between
what atom pub tries to accomplish
and what we would like to
accomplish using them as APIs.
So as I already mentioned,
there is some form of
authentication that we already
need to have in order to work
with google services and
tie in to google accounts
and we also have some way of
restricting what kind of content
that you are trying to
access using this feed
and then we need some way
to handle conflicts just in case
two people are trying to add
the same information
at the same time.
And then we have these
common elements to express
what this information is
that we're working with.
And we had some other
niceties as well
that are not part of
the atom specifications
such as batch processing
and media support.
So when we're making
a query on an atom feed
or google data feed
in this case, what is it?
Well basically it's just
a URL that contains
enough information to
tell us what kind of entries
we are to expect.
So first here,
we have a URL that describes
all of the documents
in someone's docs
and spreadsheets account.
And maybe all we really
care about is
what spreadsheets they have.
so the second URL here
is very similar to the first
but it uses a category query
to restrict only
the spreadsheet document
types in the result set.
and lastly of course
we can retrieve just each
individual entry and the
information associated with them
by passing a URL that contains
some sort of document key.
The nice thing about
google data
is that it has consistent
features across all of
our API such as
alternative output formats
like Json and RSS
in case the software you're
working with natively
consumes those formats.
It also has this
Authentication model
that we'll talk about
that allows you to
authenticate users to
their google account
and securely access
their data.
We have created
a number of client libraries
for many languages that
parse all this XML and
atom data into an easy to
use object orientated model
that you can manipulate
directly in the
language you are
comfortable with.
and we also provide some
protocol customizations like
I've said for things
that atom hasn't tackled yet
such as batch processing.
In case you want to do
a number of operations at once.
So as you can see, there are
a number of google data APIs
out there for a number of
popular google products
such as google calendar, google
spreadsheets, picasa and youtube.
So you can now access data
in any one of those products
using the same semantics
that I'm describing to you.
So for example,
lets go through
a simple way that
I might as a programmer
interact with
the google calendar API
so first I'm going to
need some way of authenticating
this request that
I'm going to be making.
So I have two options here.
One is AuthSub and
the other is ClientLogin.
ClientLogin is meant for
desktop based applications
that can have the user input
their credentials directly
and then make their request
to google's servers
where as AuthSub is intended to
allow third party websites
to re-direct users to google's
login page and then
re-direct back to
the website in question
so both of these are going
to give your program
some kind of token that
you can pass along with
your request and make it
an authenticated request.
So first let's see what
we would have to do
to retrieve all the events
in someone's calendar.
well it's very simple,
all we are doing is
pulling down a feed passing
along our credentials
and making this
authenticated request.
So when we get it back,
we get a two hundred okayed,
it means this
request was successful
and we get back an atom feed
that says some information
about the calendar such as
this Mr. Test User's calendar
and he is based out of
the Pacific time zone
But as you notice in this feed,
he didn't have any calendar
events currently on his calendar
so he is a very lonely person
and so maybe we should
invite him to lunch.
Well here I am demonstrating how
we can create an event
on his calendar,
by using the
post semantics of HTTP.
So all we're really doing is
creating an Atom entry
and then sending it to the feed.
So as you can see,
we set the start time,
eleven-thirty is time for
lunch at google
we set some information
about it in description
and we're using this category,
this kind of event
so people know this is
an atom entry
representing a calendar event.
so once we create it great,
we get a 201
created response
which means it was added to
his calendar successfully
and we get back that
same entry except now
you'll notice there is an edit
link inside of the atom entry
which allows us to go back
and make modifications
and there is a long ID there
in red which distinctly
identifies this specific event
and then you'll notice there
is a version string in blue
which represents
this revision of this event
which is of course
the first one since
we just created it.
But you notice in this
we forgot to set
where this location
is occurring in,
Mr. Test User isn't
always very bright,
so we had better tell him where
it is
we had better
edit this thing.
So now we are going to
use put to edit
the event we just created.
You notice we are
putting to the edit link
that we just saw in
the previous slide
So here we are making this
request to the edit link
with that specific revision
string that we just used
and then we are passing our
authentication information
and all we're doing is
putting the same Atom entry
except now we are adding
the bottom here in blue
the where element of specifying
that google is
based out of Mountain View
in California
So now that request has gone
through, we get an ok back
and now you can see the
latest form of the event
as on his calendar
and it has all the details
he needs to find us
and he can come eat
lunch with us, that's great
but maybe we don't really like
Mr. Test User,
he kind of talks to much
and there is a reason that no
one ever invites him to things
so we are going
to delete that event on him
before he sees it hopefully.
And so here, to delete the event
all we really need to do
is issue a delete request
with the edit URL
we just got back from
the updated form
Now notice I said the edit URL
from  the one we just got back
If we use the original edit URL
that we edited the event with,
then that would already not
work anymore since that
blue string at the end,
that version ID would be
different than it is now.
But since it is the correct
one, we get back a 200 OK.
Now if we had used the
previous one,
you would see a 409 conflict
error there
instead of a 200 OK. Which
meant that there is now
now a newer version of event
on the server than the one
that we are trying to delete.
So now that we have seen the
fifteen minute rapid fire
walk through of how to use google
data using specific things
you've got the basic idea of
what google data is
and how it works on the basic
level of XML and using HTTP
But perhaps like most people
you don't want to construct
all this XML yourself.
You might be more interested in
the high level client libraries
we support in your language of choice.
So now what you should do is
go to code.google.com/apis/gdata
to find out more and download
the client library of your choice